we have committed all of us to working
to stop the current cycle of violence in
Iraq which must cease before it's a
spirals out of control
once again this is also why I'm
convening history Foreign Affairs meters
Council on Friday coming back from
Croatia sooner than expected from which
I receive a strong mandate to carry out
all necessary diplomatic efforts to
contribute to this collation in the
region support political dialogue and
promote a political regional solution
all remaining participants in the women
have been clear of the determination to
preserve the jcpoa and this unity is
crucial and I intend to work hard to
preserve it our position the European
Union position is clear without this
deal we would lose a crucial element of
the international non-proliferation
architecture and an important
contribution to regional security a
failure to preserve the deal can only
add further tensions to the region's the
best of exotica or aware of itself with
that if a flesh tone or semi-auto mop
comments on septum the Sweden's analogue
of assets the MacLeish quietness serums
mechanisms in stakes English um 2001
Susan see his answers of a madman chef
and Mohammed is activating this put
transmission dismiss camara saw an
algorithm it is crucial to support your
efforts
High Representative to deescalate
tensions and to save the nuclear deal
with Iran this is even more important
since the triggering of the dispute
resolution mechanism earlier today but
we must also acknowledge that the
diverging interest with the current US
administration and the American
withdrawal from the region this for us
can only mean one thing that the time
has come for really
the debate on Europe strategic autonomy
to safeguard our own security and
interests
it's all yeah yeah of ridiculous
Infotech lifting Tara next in Washington
on Dartmouth in stem the rupee suppose
DC in Geneva to Humble Bundle one way to
the irreplaceable on a loop we need
sunlit Americans of the Roses La Mesa
North America no quiere terminar
colocation equation europaea case el
acuerdo nuclear Kinnear encase el único
que nos permit a Edmonton air la razón
and she does in the past que no se
produce con escalada nuclear itami arrow
record r lo al marco que NOS permit a
hablar con iran de derechos humanos que
tous estamos de acuerdo de hacer lo pero
también el g CP o es esencial pareo
hemos oído active r el megan is mo
resolutions
bueno soup odin Arenado lectura algunos
probablemente lone active Oddo por que
quieran llevarlo consejo de una de matar
el acuerdo pero yo creo que vamos in den
da root Eleazar low como una oportunidad
para discutir de todo para guiren
compliment us compromise owes pero para
también hablar de las ancien régime
puestas
que esta en estos momentos Danny and
Odin a muy importante a bolus you need
an e a pony end o ha el acuerdo
political the finis website of
dimensions so here on the dot and decent
buying land on Laban seed so respect
even initially to some order to begin
following a story that I hate streets of
Paris so far then Alicia Smith refused
it Turkish are not always on the noon as
Iraqi parliament passed persuasive
Halong toss Outlander should hope
markets walking benzoin ELISA and wolf
na hoona Peniche kite when english big
shaker in the eigen intended surname
interfere so if you understood some
korean